pas tout à fait un lieu de promenade le
boulevard doret si les dionysiens le
connaissent bien c'est qu'il a brick
l'imposant bâtiment de la sécurité
sociale mais dans ce paysage moderne et
urbain que reste-t-il de la mémoire de
d'auray est ce que vous savez qu'il
était bourré
non je ne suis pas
je sais pas vous posez une colle
vraiment non je ne sais pas aucune idée
il est important qu'à qui a dû faire
quelque chose pour la réunion et quand
on commence cette équipe je devrai était
un ancien gouverneur de l'île de la
réunion
née en 1789 en charente inférieure
louise ac pierre hilaire d'auray
commence très tôt une brillante carrière
militaire dans la marine impériale
après un épisode un peu chaotique
il gravit les échelons jusqu'à devenir
capitaine de vaisseau en 1844
en 1850 l'empereur le nomme gouverneur
de la réunion en remplacement de sarda
garriga l'abolition de l'esclavagé à
semer le trouble dans la colonie
première tâche censuré et suspendre la
liberté de la presse
il achève aussi l'indemnisation des
propriétaires d'esclaves et met en place
une banque coloniale il pousse ensuite à
la colonisation des hautes plaines et à
la diversification agricole
il fait appel aux frères des écoles
chrétiennes pour développer
l'instruction pendant ce temps madame
d'auray fait dans les bonnes oeuvres
louis de son côté créé un hospice civile
ainsi qu une léproserie mais alors que
s'ouvre une période de prospérité
une épidémie de variole se déclare elle
durera un an et tuera plus de 1400
personnes en 1852 louis do ré quittent
la réunion pour paris où l'attend un
poste de sénateur
il meurt en 1866